on retrouve à québec clément gignac vice
président principal économiste en chef à
l'industrielle-alliance clément gignac
bonsoir bonsoir c'est une chute
historique
aujourd'hui qu'on vient de connaître
définitivement parce que si on regarde
on le classe parmi les chutes les plus
importantes le évidemment là depuis la
crise financière de 2008 et un port cela
faut reculer au crash de 87 ou encore
dans la crise économique d infâme donc
d'avoir une baisse aussi important
qu'ont eue aujourd'hui la jirs a je
pense qu'on a un graphique à cet effet
là on est dans l'est libyen
on est dans le top ten de gym observée
depuis la crise des années 30 donc il ya
du sérieux sur cherche une bonne
nouvelle historiquement depuis 1000 de
seconde guerre mondiale habituellement
le lendemain neuf fois sur dix on est
plus haut mais devinez quoi gerald une
semaine après c'est uniquement six fois
sur dix ce qu'on est plus haut donc
cette voie pourrait prendre plusieurs
jours
quand il ne peut pas être plusieurs
semaines afin qu'on sache vraiment où
qu'on s'en vont avec ça est ce que on va
aller en récession non je pense qu'il
faut avoir des prochains jours ou
prochaines semaines les développements
la coronavirus pétrole ce que vous avez
mentionné dans vos propos d'ouverture
alors aujourd'hui recul de 7 8% new york
reculent de 10 à 11% à toronto depuis
les derniers sommets des reculs de 19
pour ça on est tout près de ce qu'on
appellerait un marché baissier à partir
de 20 pour ça exactement c'est la
définition marché baisser des
corrections n'y en eut plusieurs
évidemment mais marché baissier c'est
beaucoup plus rare est absolument s'est
associé à une récession c'est lorsque la
bourse baisse de 20% par rapport aux
semaines on a nos graphiques là-dessus
girafe je crois que si on regarde depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale onu pour le
au delà de 30 correction de 10% un plus
la bonne nouvelle c'est que deux fois
sur toi y'a pas de récession
et c'est une opportunité d'achat et le
marché remonter à peu près ce qu'a
tassimo neuf mois plus tard on a tout
récupéré ce n'était qu'un mauvais
souvenir
mais quand même une fois sur toi donc
pas loin de 11 occasions qu'on a vu que
ça continue à baisser puis la baisse
moyenne faut bien attacher votre
ceinture
on parle même d'une baisse moyenne de 35
pour simple à d'un lieu de 50% donc fort
explique bien graphique là oui parce que
son arrivée la chute qu'on a connu déjà
là on en a déjà 12 % puis une petite
étoile qui démontre à la date de clôture
de ce soir là on n'est déjà pas loin du
vieux et du neuf pour un bien long on
commence à se rapprocher de la petite
courbe en rouge qui démontre que si on
est en récession
on pourrait connaître un autre 10 15% de
baisse et si on se fie à la moyenne
historique la rue main mais s'ils sont
fervents récession donc sa grosse caisse
qu'est ce que je veux vous poser
premièrement pour l'économie américaine
c'est vrai que les produits ont augmenté
leur travail plus du 20-25 % comme vous
avez mentionné bleus deux semaines en
raison de ce qui se passe
la décision de le peuple au pied
l'arabie saoudite la russie qui de leurs
avoirs s'attaquer au préfet au pétrole
de schiste aux états unis on voit les
titres bancaires aux états unis qui ont
baissé de nos 10 % aujourd'hui
là on vient toucher des fondements de
l'économie américaine
donc oui les projeter de récession sont
peut-être plus rendu à 40% aux
etats-unis dans le code du canada je
dois même les relevés pour le moins de
45 50 % parce qu'en plus nous on est un
produit un pays exportateurs de pétrole
est donc clairement ça nous fera pas
encore beaucoup plus c'est ça sera la
récession malheureusement en alberta à
moins que la russie arrive se dit
décidée une semaine de revenir à de
meilleures intentions et de s'entendre
couper la production au lieu de le
relever parce que là on a le corps d'un
virus qui nous malmène depuis quelques
temps qui crée énormément d'incertitudes
dans les services le tourisme
cette erreur et là d'un coup sec on voit
cette bataille sur le pétrole ou les
deux géants ne s'entendent pas sur une
réduction du pétrole donc plutôt que de
réduire le pétrole soutenir les prix
mais on augmente la production alors
qu'on a une demande mondiale qui
ralentit qu'on avait dû couper la
production d'un million et demi 2
million baril par jour on voit même
l'augmenter donc on tombe dans une
guerre de prix
évidemment la bri a dit c'est le pays au
monde le coût de production les plus
faibles donc il pourrait bien décider
pendant six mois 1,1 d'avoir un prix de
25 $ évidemment y perdre de l'argent
mais ça va faire très mal aux sables
bitumineux a instruit des pétroles de
schiste aux états unis et là c'est pour
éliminer des concurrents
si on faisait ça donc ça reste à voir on
est rendu dans le jeu aux politiques de
gerald parce que gardons l'esprit qu'on
est dans le midwest américain etc des
états qui sont en faveur de monsieur
tron
si on attaque ça est ce qu on compromet
les réélections de monsieur tron et là
on est dans un autre monde avec
peut-être les démocrates qui pourraient
augmenter les taux corporatif donc comme
fait voir c'est encore très très volatil
et ça prendra encore plusieurs jours
posait plusieurs semaines pour savoir à
quoi s'en tenir vraiment où on s'en va
avec tout ce scénario là alors on a vu
le pétrole plonge et on voit les marchés
plongée et on voit les taux obligataires
plongée et donc les gens se déplacent
beaucoup il ya beaucoup d'investisseurs
qui vont vers les obligations fortement
mais ce qui fait baisser donc les taux
et quand on regarde les obligations
canadiennes à 10 ans le 1er janvier 2020
on est à 1,7 pour cent le taux est là on
est à 0 25% qu'est ce que ça nous envoie
comme message ça nous envoie que le
marché obligataire lui il croit vraiment
qu'on s'en va vers une récession
donc faut revoir gardons l'esprit que
les taux obligataires en europe sont
même négatif nous les trouve très beau
mais devinez quoi ils sont très gros par
rapport à ce qu'on voit en europe
donc ça donc pour les gens qui nous
écoutent le portefeuille ceux qui ont
des fonds diversifiés que des
obligations et des actions quand les
taux de mon bain de prises obligations
prend de la valeur
donc oui sont affectés mais un
portefeuille diversifié s'en tire pas
trop mal finalement
mais clairement quelqu'un qui est 100 %
la bourse actuellement on brûle un peu
des lampions pour que l'on puisse
découvrir un vaccin le plus tôt possible
pour que dans trois ou six mois on met
en production qu'on puisse dire ok c'est
une forme de v une récession
d'économistes qui aura duré peut-être
trois quatre cinq six mois mais
finalement qu'une reprise est là c'est
une belle opportunité d'achat mais pour
ça il faudra qu'on ait des
développements du côté du corn au virus
on s'habille lise l'écho et on est un
vaccin qui se présentent bientôt ou bien
de meilleures intentions de la part de
l'arabie saudite et du côté de la russie
et donc on doit les uns essaient de
garneau mais le monocle et remet ses
canada et le pays modèle en termes de
gestion de finances publiques on est les
moins endettés on pourrait y aller avec
des mesures temporaires faut revoir
est ce qu'on y voit avec des stimuli
haut niveau
ce call une réduction de la tps pendant
toi six mois de 3 4% pour inciter les
gens consommaient davantage
est ce qu'on y va avec des dépenses
d'infrastructures donc une réunion que
les premiers ministres provinciaux
puis je pense qu'on va commencer à
réfléchir à des scénarios pour être sûr
que le canada tombe pas dans une
récession aussi c'est une récession une
récession plus technique la dure qui
dure peut-être juste trois quatre mois
et pas très profonde
merci beaucoup clément gignac pour
s'être très intéressante et importante
analyse ce soir merci au plaisir